حد هنا كان ثانويه عامه وكان نفسه يدخل طب
او هندسه ومجموعه ما جابش
اكيد كثير اكيد انا جايبها مش افكرك
باحباطك في ثانويه عامه ولكن انا جاي
اسالك سؤال ثاني انت اتصرفت ازاي وقتها
وازاي اخترت الكليه اللي انت موجود فيها
حاليا او اللي خرجت منها
وعشان مضيعش وقتك يعني باقول لك اللي انت
كنت واحد واثنين
يا اما مكنتش عندك اي داتا تماما اول ما
تعرفش منين يولد فين وفيه مقوله مشهوره
بتقول اذا كنت لا تعلم الى اين تتجه فكل
الطرق
وبالتالي في الغالب اللي انت عملته وقتها
انك استخسرت المجموع بتاعك وبدات تشوف ايه
الكليه لتنسيقها بعدها هندسه او طب وهي
ايه بالضبط واخرتها وتوكلت على الله او
انك ست اهلك اللي يختاره لك يختاروا لك
بمطايات زمانهم هم في الزمن الحالي بتاعك
الاختيار اللي بنسبه كبيره مش هيطلع صحيحه
قوي
او ان كنت شخص ثاني
ومحدد انت عايز بالضبط هدفك الفلوس الكليه
بتقدر تحقق لك اكبر عقد
وكنت متوقع ان في ثلاث كليات يقدر يعملوا
لك مستقبلك او يحدده لك اكبر عدد بس انت
شخص برجماتي قوي عايز تعرف مين فيهم
الالفا مين فيهم اكثر كليه هتقدر تحقق لك
اللي انت بتحلم به
فبدات تعمل ايه بقى بدات تسال الناس اللي
حواليك اللي متخرجين من الكليات رحت مثلا
ل- اا ابن عمك اللي شغال صيدليس قال له
انت مرتبك كم في شهر تقريبا قال لك انا
بقبض في حدود ال 500$ قلت تمام ماشي
التاريخ 5000 دولار هو شغال كيميائي خرج
من كليه علوم
الموضوع عينيك بدات تلمع وحبيت الكليه
دولار فحسيت بالاحباط وقررت
بس عشان تتاكد اكتر رحت اسال عدد اكبر من
الناس وتشوف اكبر قدر من الناس اللي كانت
متخرجه من الكليات دي وتشوف مرتبات قد ايه
فلقيت ان الموضوع مش زي المتوقع ده
الموضوع متفاوت في ناس كيميائيين بيقبضوا
مرتبات عاليه جدا
نفس الكلام ينطبق على الصيادله ونفس
الكلام ينطبق على المبرمجين فلقيت نفسك في
حيره
ورجعت لنفس النقطه ثاني انت مش قادر انك
تاخذ قرار اي حد بياخذ قرار بيبقى واقع في
الفخ ده يا اما ما عندوش اي بيانات يا اما
عنده بيانات كتير جدا مش قادر يحدد منها
هو ينفع ايه بالضبط
بس الحاله الثانيه فرصها افضل شويه ده
خلاك تقول بقى ايه انا هادرس كل بيانات
على كده واشوف شكل البنات دي كان عامل
ازاي فبدات بالصيادله تشوف شكل البيانات
بتاعتهم عامله ازاي فالقيت ان مرتباتهم
كانت طالعه بالمنظر ده المرتبات اللي سالت
عليها كانت بتبدا من 200 دولار لحد 5000
دولار لكن الغالبيه العظمى من الصيادله
كانوا بيقبضوا في حدود ال 500 دولار
يزيدوا او يقول له 200 دولار
الصيدلي زيه زي معظم
الصيادله انت كمان
نفس الكلام ده
ابن عمك ورحت المرتبات اللي هو
الكيميائيين لقيت ان نفس الكيرم كان طالع
لك هو هو والمرتبات في برده بتتراوح من
5000 دولار لكن هنا كان معظم المرتبات في
حدود 400 دولار في زد لها 100$ او تقللها
100 دولار وبالتالي استنتجت ان وضعهم مش
افضل قوي من الصيادلهم تقريبا وابن خالتك
ده كان استثناء وان هو موجود اصلا
الغالبيه العظمى ما بتقبضش زيه وبالتالي
لو دخلت كليه علوم فانت ايه ده الاغلبيه
فبدات تتغير فكرتك من الكليه وتشوف الكليه
اللي بعدها
شفت بنات المبرمجين لقيت ان نفس الكيرف
برده كان طالع لك وان المرتبات بتلعب في
نفس الرينج لكنك لقيت ان مرتبات الغالبيه
العظمى كانت تقريبا في حدود ال 1500 دولار
تزيد لها 500 دولار او تقل 500 دولار
وبالتالي جارك اللي انت كنت محبط منه ده
استثناء برده مش ده الغالبيه ولو دخلت نفس
الكليه في الاحتمال الاكبر انك هتخبط زي
الناس دي ايه اللي هيخليك تبقى زي
الاستثناء
فبدات مثلا تدخل على الانترنت تشوف ليه
المنحنى وايه القصه وراء ده
طالما دورت لقيت ان محمد مشهور اسمه منحنى
التوزيع الطبيعي او النور
الطبيعيه بتخضع لنفس التوزيع ده كلها كلها
المنحنى ده
في خاصيه مهمه جدا ان كل الاحتمالات فيهم
كده عشان كده لقيت ان في كل وظيفه سالت
عنها
كانت المرتبات موجوده ال 200 دولار لحد
5000 دولار ولو كنت اخذت عينه اكبر من
اللي انت اخذتها كنت هتلاقي مرتبات اقل
ومرتبات اعلى من اللي موجوده دي لكن كان
من ضمن
الغالبيه العظمى او الرنج اللي له
احتماليه اكبر ليه بقى متوزع حوالين نقطه
في منتصف المنحنى بيقولوا عليها المتوسط
وعرفت ان مصطلح يزيد او يقل اللي انا كنت
عمال برضده في كل وظيفه منهم ده مصطلح
مشهور بيسموه الاسكندر ديفيشن او الانحراف
المعياري ودي قيمه مهمه جدا
لان الرينج اللي بيبقى موجود في اول
انحراف المعياري احتماليه ظهوره بتبقى 68%
والرينج اللي بيبقى موجود في اثنين انحراف
معياري احتمالياته بتبقى 95% وبالتالي
القيم اللي بره الرينج ده احتملتها هتبقى
كم اطرح
5% او اقل من 5% عشان كده
ابن خالتك ده
احتماليه وجوده وصلت لمين اقل من 5% ونفس
الكلام على دارك كان استثناء احتماليه
وجوده وصل مبرمجين اقل من 5% ولو اشتغلت
نفس شغلنتهم انت مش هتبقى زيهم اصلا انت
في الغالب هتبقى زي 95% اللي موجودين في
اثنين انحراف المعياري
كمان
وظيفته يعمل اللي انت عملته بالضبط
هو داخل في كل حاجه في حياتك كل حاجه كل
حاجه
طيب بمناسبه ان احنا في كاس العالم حاليا
واللي انتم سايبين ماتش المغرب
فنتكلم عن كره القدم
كره القدم مبنيه كلها على الاحصائيات
ومش باقول لك هنا مثلا احصائيات او ارقام
اللعيبه وانت بتشتري لعيب اهو هتبيعه
فبتشوف ارقامه عامله ازاي لا ده انا بقول
لك على نفسه اسلوب اللعب بيتغير على حسب
الاحصائيات
وتجيب جون لو ان الاحتماليه دي بتقل كل ما
بعدت عن المراه اللي لدرجه ان في المناطق
في الملعب لو شفتم منها احتماليه انك تجيب
جون
دكات تكون منعدمه ده معك عشان تخلي
المديريه الفنيين يمنعوا اللعيبه ان هو
ممنوع من المناطق اللي زي دي طب انا عكس
على ايه في البريميرليج من 2011 الى 2020
عدد التسديدات قال لي بصوره كبيره في
الجيم الواحد وعدد التسديدات اللي من خارج
منطقه الجزاء قلب في اقل اكثر من من
النسبه اللي قبلها وبالتالي في قرار
التاخد بناء على المعطيات على الاحصائيات
وان كنت مش مهتمه قوي كره القدم فانا عايز
اقول لك ان الادويه والعقاقير من اكثر
الحاجات اللي بتدخل فيها الاحصنه
ما فيش عقار موجود فعال بنسبه 100% ما فيش
مقاطع مقاطع ما فيش
عقار شمال
عليه وصفه سحريه مش طبيعي لانه لو كان
طبيعي
هيخضع للتوزيع الطبيعي
عشان كده ما فيش عقار فعاد بنسبه 100% لو
في عقار موجود
في ناس مش هتستجيب
طيب تاخذ الاغراض من كده ما فيش اي ماده
عشوائيه ما لهاش اي تاثير دوائي
لدرجه ان انت لو جبت شويه سكر واديتهم
لمريض سكر ممكن تعالجه من السكر طبعا انا
في ناس
جدا جدا
عشان كده الشركات الادويه لما بتيجي تجرب
عقار جديد
ما بتقولش من العقار ده كان شافها فلان او
اعلان او نسبه تاثيره على الناس كانت
معينه لا ده بتقول ان العقار بتقارن
نسبه الناس اللي خفوا من العقاري الجديد
اللي هم عملوه مع نسبه الناس اللي خافوا
من اي ماده وهميه بيسموها البلاستيب ولو
فيكم حد هنا في طب او صيدله ولو الفرق ما
بينهم ده كان واضح
بيسموه في الاحصنه ساعتها بيقولوا ان
الدواء الجديد دفعات ولو ما فيش فرق
بيعتبروه اي كلام
شيت التحاليل الطبيه اللي انت بتمسكه
دائما
بتقارن النسب اللي فيه او ريفر رينج اللي
موجود عشان تعرف انت عندك مشاكل ولا لا
حد يعرف حسب
جابه تحاليل ناس كثيره جدا
فهي دي النتائج القيمه الطبيعيه 95% من
الناس منطبق عليهم الكلام
وبالتالي لو جيت مثلا تمسك شيء تحليل طبيه
وليه نفسك
اعلى من القيمه اللي في التقرير اوان فانت
بنسبه 95% عندك مشكله
لكن بنسبه 5% انك استثناء وانك شخص طبيعي
وان قيمتك دي كانت بره ال 95% بتوع الناس
دول ممكن تكون سليم وقيمه بعيده عن همم
نيجي بقى للحاجات دي كلها اللي فات دي كل
الحاجات اللي انت تقدر
تكون عندك لها كومنت او حاسس بتدخل فيها
تعال بقى اقول لك على حاجات انت لا تتوقع
الاحتمالات
درجه الحراره مثلا كوبايه الشاي اللي
تمسكها درجه حرارتها 100 درجه
ليه درجه حرارتها من الدرجه
لان معظم جزيئات الميه اللي موجوده في
الكوبايه درجه حرارتها بتلعب حوالين الضرب
لكن في الكوبايه برده في جزيئات ميه درجه
حرارتها سفر درجه
حرارتها 1000 درجه مئويه احتمال موجود
مع عدد الجزيئات الرهيب اللي موجود جوه
الكوبايه موجود
ولو انت مش مصدقني في التوزيع ده اللي درس
فيكم ديناميكا الحراريه او ثيرموكس بيسموه
توزيع ماكسويل
اللي عملوه وممكن ترجعوله
بدات انت تستغرب شويه تمام طب تعالى بقى
اخليك تتخض اكثر
كوبايه الشاي دي لو سبتها ايه اللي هيحصل
اعتبرها صح ليه هتبرد
لكن دي مش الاحتماليه الوحيده لو عندك عدد
لا نهائي
في كوبايات منهم
انت بتاخذ الاضرب في كوبايات منهم درجه
حرارتهم هترتفع مش هتقل
مستغرب صح
الداله دي دوله برده اللي في درس
اسمها العشوائيه او الانتروبي
وممكن واللي عملها بالمناسبه
انتحر وتقريبا كل اللي اشتغلوا على
الديناميكا الحراريه والاحصائيات معظمهم
ماتوا منتحرين يعني طب نيجي بقى للاغرب
اكيد لابد انك تكون سمعت
له طبيعه وزوجه
صح
طيب انت عارف ان هو جسيم وموجه
الموجه
دي عباره عن ايه
حد يعرف
دي موجه من
الاحتمالات
يعني ايه يعني الالكتروني موجود في كل حته
بس باحتمالات مختلفه ما اقدرش اقول ان
الالكترونات
وطبعا يعني الكترون ده الماده يعني الكون
الاجهزه في النهايه طلع احتمالي كل حاجه
في الكون احتمالات وبالتالي لو هتدرس
الاحتمالات لازم تدرسها بالاحتمالات ما
ينفعش تدرس
وانا كنت بدات الكلمه بتاعتي
وانت دايما بتدور
ازاي تكون في ال 95% مع الغالبيه العظمى
لان هو ده
بس بعد ما عرفت ان كل الاحتمالات ورده تحت
المنحنى كل الاحتمالات ورد
ليه ما تفكرش
تبقى
ليه ما تبقاش هي 5%
ليه ما تبقاش ابن خالتك شكرا جزيلا لك
[تصفيق]